a crack in the cement can symbolize a
fork in the road
but a friend's faith and another can
help illuminate a path not living with a
purpose any person this from the heart I
ain't spent too much time rehearsing I
was really thinking Rob before I
purchase I tell him oh I'll always
appreciate him for showing the world he
was my man like that catalyst by my
first official supporter
me and him we go back deep with that
ball is just crazy high so me I was
worthless
I felt like I was cursed until the day a
paper surface David Brewster jr. known
today as rap star Dave East was born and
raised in a Harlem neighborhood of New
York City by high school East was a
standout basketball prospect in 2003 he
was recruited to play down in a highly
competitive Washington DC area that's
when he met another emerging basketball
phenom Matt I'm just from being around
the gym just being around a you circuit
coming up in high school you start to
hear about players all over the state
it was dead nice the first the first day
I got there to go we just like play
pickup Kevin yeah you run into somebody
you all know but they be nice now you
got something in common you got
something to talk about all right we'll
keep up with this boo cuz you know what
I do that next year he blew up until
being one of the best players in that
area and he was all state or county he
was all world for us and it felt like we
had another one coming out of our area I
was going to potentially make City NBA
durant and east both went on to play
Division one college ball Durant was a
one-and-done standout at Texas East
initially played at the University of
Richmond before transferring to Towson
University in Baltimore we just really
just stayed connected and when I got
there Kevin older brother Tony the rent
was my roommate
small world you know saying so then we
really got close and and my brother
played college ball together and they
were roommates so we got tight that way
I say no writing down raps all the time
I see him with the headphones on I'm
watching my friends I was working out
with the leaves I was like maybe the
same for me mama and Kevin when Harry
got drafted you know I started doing the
rap my life was rough at that point I'm
still in the projects trying to figure
out what I'm eating for the bit it was
rough leaving balling long and then
going to a hood with his basketball
career fading he struggled initially to
break in as an artist without the game
they're struggling lyricist went down
darker avenues I was incarcerated for
low-tom I'm in jail and then back in the
projects I found used to classrooms big
beautiful gym I was away from all that
so it hurt but it like with my character
I had a change of plans only work about
the rent I linked up with my bro AJ he
had our studio and I'd be excited by
y'all got studio two hours a night I'm
trying to knock out full of joints if I
can and from me I said you know what I'm
gonna do a mixtape this is his name it
changing players pump is still lucky
runner beasts and he's focused all his
energies into his true passion though to
himself into a rising underground MC his
growth as an artist led to his first
aptly titled mixtape when I first heard
it I was surprised by pigeonhole him to
just being a basketball player so when I
first heard it just being a fan of music
I was surprised that cuz it's hard to
rap it's hard to come up with music and
lines I told him I I'm started to get
into music and I'm starting to try to
figure out how how to make music tell
him to come on out and see what I was
doing and see where I had and
potentially just like getting a studio
you know just be around some good
creativity I'm talking to Kevin at this
at this point me I'm talking every day
on my yell bro
he actually was reaching out to people
for beats for me like I wasn't going on
Twitter and all that at the time I'd be
like yo I'm in the studio with my guy oh
my god a studio same beast to this email
so now I'm getting beats from top
producers remember that Memphis series
when we played on 2011 I remember like
it was yesterday it was like in between
Game six and Game seven and we just went
in there and we listened to a few beats
and he went understood in a in the booth
and rolled it on the pad and like ten
minutes he wrote one song and then he
found the rhythm and he just kept going
back and forth and we went for two days
when I get in studio I'm doing another
song and I'm gonna at that point in my
mind I'm like marinating blew me away
I'm gonna scream I'm gonna be paying for
these studio sessions like I'm working
I'm not wasting no time I can be on my
from what I was doing I was going from
beat the beat usually when it's crunch
time that's when that's when these
artists come up with the most clever
you know concepts and ideas and he came
up with some some ideas that had me
thinking that if seeing everything in
his mind and he just had to put it down
I treat right like bull I liked it so
hard and I seen I had Katie behind it
and I had the streets behind it I just
told myself let's do it let's go and I
mean like give it everything he spent
six weeks at Durant's house creating
what would be his defining mixtape
generating a buzz that would catch the
ear of one of the genres greatest
lyricists I got a quote from NAS who's
telling y'all over to door and I mean
you remind me of myself I got to like a
label called masa collecting tsunami
check it out if you want to get down
let's do it
the basketball player formerly known as
David Brewster jr. is now Dave East the
hottest rising MC out of New York City
[Music]
his authentic storytelling is beloved by
both fans and players alike I know so
many people wanna feature from one wanna
hop on a song we don't want to give him
B's I'm just more just happy that he's
doing something that he loves to do he's
provide for his family that's that's
just that's just that takes it all for
me so I would love to be in there when
he makes his next record and I wanna see
the process down from where it was
before but if anything I'm just there
for support now looking back on it that
was a that was epic and I mean even do
something like that at that point in my
career I wasn't really nobody you know I
mean he had enough faith for me to take
the time out of his day and his schedule
to come I was gonna steal
[Music]